*recherche sur Google VIDE GRENIER DE FLO ET GABI*
- Salut c'est Flo !
- Salut c'est Gabi !
Pour le vide grenier de Flo et Gabi !
Cette semaine on a trouvé pas mal de nouveaux jeux
Dans un vide grenier à côté de chez nous, on va vous montrer nos trouvailles
On a acheté une Game & Watch en très bon état
- On a réussi à trouver des jeux Famicom
- En très bon état
- A la semaine prochaine !
- N'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo
A la semaine prochaine !
J'espère qu'on va trouver des trucs.
Ce serait bien de trouver des jeux vidéo.
Tu n'achètes rien aujourd'hui, on a plus d'argent, il faut payer le loyer, les courses...
Oui ne t'inquiètes pas...
Gabi, tu le surveilles ! Si je vous coince un de vos jeux vidéo la gorge pour vous étouffer avec !
- Oui Cathy...
- Cool.
A tout à l'heure mon amour.
- On s'en bat les couilles ?
- Totalement.
Il y a du monde !
- T'as combien d'argent ?
- J'ai cinq euros.
- Tu vois des jeux ?
- Pas grand chose.
Là !
C'est combien ?
Cinq euros l'album, ça vous va ?
On parle des jeux.
C'est des jeux ? Je pensais que c'était des cassettes.
Ce sont des vieux trucs à mon père, j'y connais rien.
Les jeux vidéo c'est pour les gamins !
Pourtant vous jouez à un jeu.
C'est pas un jeu c'est un application.
Il y connait rien, négocie.
Pour 10 euros, on va vous prendre ce jeu et...
Pour 10 euros prenez le carton !
- T'es trop doué pour les négociations !
- Merci !
Merci monsieur, au revoir.
J'ai ça aussi.
C'est un jeu, non ?
Vous le voulez ?
Oui, pour un euro...
Je vous le donne.
T'es trop fort !
Il y a un autocollant dessus, je vous l'enlève.
Non c'est bon.
Merci monsieur, bonne journée.
On a fait une affaire de fou ! On rentre pour faire une vidéo !
Regarde ! Il y a même une cartouche de MegaMan 2 !
C'est un de mes jeux préférés, on l'a en double mais c'était pas cher.
- On se retrouve la semaine...
- Attend il y avait un autre jeu.
On a pas eu le temps de l'essayer et c'est écrit en chinois dessus
si quelqu'un lit le chinois, laissez un commentaire.
A la semaine prochaine !
Salut les puceaux.
Oh non, pas ma soeur...
Je te rappelle que je ne suis pas puceaux, j'ai une copine.
Toi OK mais mon frère il vierge de tout contact avec un être humain.
Ça va Tiphaine, je t'ai rien fait.
C'est ça le problème, tu fais rien dans ta piaule qui pue et tes jeux vidéo de merde.
Ça te dirait pas d'être un homme ? Te confronter à la réalité ?
Demain j'ai une pote qui vient à la maison, tu me fous pas la honte, tu restes dans ta chambre.
Si tu veux plus me voir t'as qu'à te casser !
Justement, je me casse 6 mois aux États-Unis pour mon MBA.
Genre tu fais du basket !
T'es pas assez grande !
MBA pas NBA ducon, ce sont des études supérieures. Vous êtes vraiment débiles.
Et ouvrez cette fenêtre, ça pue le gouda !
Elle est dégoûtée parce que c'est moi qui commande à la maison.
Hé, Tiphaine !
Quoi ?
Ouais, je préfère...
Tiens, regarde les commentaires.
"C'est pas du chinois, c'est du japonais"
C'est pareil non ?
"Je lis le japonais, il est écrit MERCI D'EN PRENDRE SOIN"
"C'est la signature de Shigeru Miyamoto le créateur de Mario Bros., non ?"
*recherche Google SIGNATURE MIYAMOTO*
"Ça me fait penser à une interview de Miyamoto, regardez"
Pourquoi ça marche pas ?
Attends !
On a le tout premier Mario !
Le tout premier Mario !
- Redis-le !
- On a le premier Mario !
- Encore !
- On a le tout premier Mario !
Non attend ! On s'emballe pas.
Ça se trouve c'est une blague.
Le seul moyen d'être sûr c'est de demander à Miyamoto.
Oui. Bouge pas, je l'appelle tout de suite.
Flo, tu n'as pas le numéro de Miyamoto.
Bah du coup comment on fait pour le contacter ?
T'y as pensé à ça ? Comment on le contacte ?
Sans ton visage.
- Tu penses que ça va marcher ?
- Je sais pas mais c'est le seul moyen d'être sûr.
*TWEET : Est-ce la cartouche que vous avez perdu ?*
On fait quoi en attendant qu'il réponde ?
Comme tous les soirs : passer un moment avec des filles et boire de l'alcool !
C'est un bug ?
On commence avec la news du jour, tout le monde en parle sur les réseaux sociaux.
J'ai découvert ça sur Twitter : quelqu'un a découvert la première cartouche de Mario !
C'est le Graal de tous les amateurs de jeux vidéo, c'est génial que deux gars l'aient découvert.
C'est pas une blague car Miyamoto a confirmé que c'était le vrai prototype !
Si la cartouche prend trop de place chez toi, tu peux me la donner !
C'est la vraie cartouche ! C'est la vraie cartouche !
Gabi ! Fais-toi discret !
- C'est qui ?
- C'est mon frère le puceau et son pote attardé.
Il est vraiment puceau ton frère ?
Tiphaine, on a le tout premier Mario !
Ok, il est bien puceau...
Et la fenêtre, ouvrez-la ! Ça sent le cul de vieux !
- C'est génial !
- Ça doit valoir une fortune !
C'est inestimable, c'est le rêve de tous les collectionneurs !
On va faire une vidéo pour en parler !
Attend, avant ça...
Bonjour monsieur, on aimerait que vous estimiez le prix de ce jeu.
Ça vaut dans les 10 euros, je peux vous les donner tout de suite.
- Ok, je vous en donne 10.000 euros.
- 10.000 euros ?!
- Merci pour l'info...
- Attend ! Monsieur n'a pas fini sa discussion !
- Ok, 20.000 euros c'est mon dernier prix !
- 20.000 euros ?!
On est millionnaires ! Qu'est-ce qu'on va acheter avec tout ça ?
Maintenant on connait sa valeur, merci Monsieur, on va y aller.
- J'ai dit 20.000 ? Je voulais dire 25.000 !
- Tu négocies tellement bien !
30.000 ! C'est mon dernier prix !
Attendez ! Gabi !
Gabi ! Reviens !
Gabi ! 30.000 euros ! Tu te comptes de tout l'argent que ça fait ?
On va pouvoir s'acheter plein de chose !
Flo, on va pas vendre la cartouche.
Comment ? T'as entendu le prix du vendeur ?
Maintenant on sait sa valeur pour notre collection, mais on va pas la vendre.
Gabi ! Une offre comme ça, ça ne se refuse pas !
Si, on vient juste de le faire.
Tu viens de le faire ! On a acheté cette cartouche tous les deux, pourquoi tu prendrais les décisions seul ?
Tu veux t'en débarasser, cette cartouche il n'y en a qu'une, de l'argent il y en a partout dans le monde !
Comment je fais pour payer mon loyer ? Je peux pas le payer avec une cartouche, réfléchis !
C'est pas ma faute si t'arrives pas à garder un boulot plus de trois jours !
Moi au moins je vis pas chez mes parents qui me payent tout.
Dis que je suis un fils à papa tant que t'y es !
Exactement ! Ça c'est l'occasion pour toi de faire quelque chose d'adulte !
Trouver quelqu'un, trouver un appart.
Mais non tu préfères rester dans ta chambre entretenu par tes parents comme...
Comme quoi ?
Comme un puceau !
- Je peux monter le prix...
- Ferme ta gueule !
Tu vois cette cartouche ? Jamais on la vendra !
- Si t'es pas content tu peux te casser !
- Très bien je me casse !
- Casse-toi !
- Je verrai plus ta gueule de puceau !
Et moi je verrai plus ta gueule de...
- Les portes c'est pas fait pour...
- Ta gueule ! Dégage !
Bonjour c'est Gabi pour le vide grenier de Gabi !
Maintenant je suis tout seul, mon pote c'est plus mon pote et c'est mieux comme ça.
C'est pas important. Ça c'est important !
Je sais pas si vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé sur internet
je suis fier de vous présenter l'objet le plus précieux pour les collectionneurs de jeux vidéo
Le tout premier Mario du monde.
Avec la signature du créateur et c'est ma cartouche.
Je ne vais jamais la vendre !
Mettez un pouce en l'air sur la vidéo, merci de me suivre, à la semaine prochaine !
T'inquiètes pas, ça va passer avec Gabi.
Ne me parle plus jamais de lui, il n'a jamais existé.
Il y a une nouvelle vidéo sur votre chaîne YouTube.
Je m'en fous.
*J'espère que Flo va revenir !*
*On s'en fout de ton jeu ! ON VEUT FLO !*
*Vous êtes fachés, toi et Flo ?*
*Je suis sûre que Flo va revenir !*
Je sais comment te remonter le moral : une partie de Mario Kart !
Non pas ce soir.
- T'as jamais refusé une partie de Mario Kart.
- Ce soir je refuse.
*Salut c'est Flo, salut c'est Gabi pour le vide grenier de Flo et Gabi !*
*spécial Noël !*
*le mec nous a vendu le jeu pour un euro ! On le prend pour un euro alors !*
*Joyeux anniversaire*
*Un cadeau pour toi Flo*
*C'est le premier Zelda sur NES*
Ça va ?
Laisse -moi tranquille...
Si t'as besoin de parler je suis à côté.
Si tu veux que je t'apprenne à embrasser une fille...
Bonjour c'est Gabi, je fais une vidéo spéciale...
C'est une vidéo d'excuse pour Flo.
Je suis désolé Flo.
Tout est allé vite, j'ai pas réagi comme il fallait.
Je pense qu'on doit rester potes.
Tu peux revenir quand tu veux.
*Publier la video :
Maintenant - Plus tard*
Encore désolé.
*Publier la vidéo : Plus tard*
Qu'est-ce qui va pas chez toi ?
Comme ça tu m'exclues des vidéos et tu gardes la cartouche pour toi ?
Attend, je peux t'expliquer...
Maintenant la cartouche elle est à moi.
Flo, ne fais pas ça ! Non !
Attention Flo, non ! Non !
- Vous ?
- Quel hasard ! Je me promenais par là...
- On avait dit combien ? 5.000 euros ?
- Non plus ! 2.000 !
Je cherche mon stylo...
- Rend la cartouche !
- J'ai le stylo !
Ça y est, tu l'as maintenant ta tortue !
- Tu vas y faire attention.
- Bien sûr maman.
Reviens !
Il fallait faire attention...
- Elle est à moi !
- Non c'est à moi !
Maintenant Flo, t'arrêtes tes conneries, tu rends la cartouche !
Non ! Pourquoi c'est toi qui devrait la garder ?
Parce que toi tu veux t'en débarrasser !
Lâche !
- C'est la mienne !
- C'est à moi !
*Cartouche en 3D qui vole*
Elle est où ?
Vous avez pas vu une cartouche ?
On l'a faite tomber !
T'es trop con ! À cause de toi on a perdu la cartouche !
Tout le monde pense que t'es débile et je comprends mieux pourquoi !
Je préfère être débile que puceau !
Oh les gamins, on se calme !
T'as vu les gamins là ? Viens on les tabasse !
C'est pas une bonne idée.
Un mec en pyjama Mario dans une cellule c'est forcément un tueur en série.
T'as raison...
Flo, je tenais à m'excuser.
Non, c'est de ma faute. À cause de moi on a perdu la cartouche.
C'est pas grave, j'ai perdu plus précieux que ça.
Un ami.
Et ça, ça a plus de valeur que tous les jeux du monde.
On a peut-être perdu une cartouche mais... tu viens de retrouver un ami !
Tu tapes fort quand même !
- Je fais de la boxe.
- Ah oui ?
Dans Wii Sports.
Gabi, t'étais où ? Ton pote débarque comme ça et tu pars en pyjama...
T'as quoi au visage ?
- Je me suis battu...
- Tu t'es battu ? Toi ?
Avec ton corps, tes bras et tout ?
T'étais où ?
- J'étais en garde à vue.
- En garde à vue ?
Tu t'es battu, j'y crois pas...
T'es peut-être un bonhomme finalement.
Par contre ne va pas en prison, c'est pas être un homme ça, c'est juste stupide.
Mon frère s'est battu !
Désolé.
*SMS : RDV au Retro Store*
Tu cherches Flo ? Il est à l'intérieur.
Bienvenue chez Retro Store, chers clients !
T'as retrouvé un boulot ?
T'as vu ça ! En plus le boulot de rêve, je suis entouré de jeux.
Je savais qu'il allait y arriver, c'est le meilleur.
Je savais pas qu'ils embauchaient !
J'ai fait croire au patron que j'avais encore la cartouche et que je réfléchirais à lui vendre si il m'embauchait.
C'était mon idée à la base.
C'est malin !
J'a négocié mon salaire, je suis à 900 euros par mois !
T'as fait quoi ?
C'est moins que le salaire minimum Flo...
Je me gave !
Bonjour, c'est vous Flo et Gabi du vide grenier de Flo et Gabi ?
- Oui !
- T'as besoin de quelque chose ?
Tiens Gabi, c'est mon numéro de téléphone.
Prend le papier...
Prend le !
Mais vous avez vu sa gueule ?
Tu sais Gabi, un jour...
Il va falloir que tu niques.
C'est important.
- Une fois j'ai niqué.
- Non.
- Je crois...
Papa !
Regarde ce que j'ai trouvé. Je sais pas ce que c'est.
C'est une cartouche de jeu. Je crois que j'ai encore la console !
Regarde.
Le vieux truc... Tu jouais avec ça ?
J'adorais ce jeu quand j'avais ton âge.
Mais c'est nul !
C'est nul ? Je passais ma vie dessus !
J'ai gagné !
- On refait une partie ?
- OK !
- Est-ce que t'arrive à jouer comme ça ?
- Tu triches !
Tu sais comment on jouais à l'époque ?
On jouais comme ça !
Attention la console !